when you start to look at the on-chain
cost basis the the funding rate i think
for most people uh it's interesting they
understand it right you're doing a great
job explaining it uh but to me this idea
of on-chain cost basis and are we above
or below where that is seems to be like
a really really important uh component
and right now we're sitting below this
so first describe what exactly is on
chain cost basis and then what what does
it mean when we're below it for a period
of time for technical traders the way
you can think of this is a volume
weighted average price
but for anybody who's not technical it's
just looking at the average you know
price that investors bought in and
specifically we're looking at short-term
holders so these are entities who have
held their bitcoin for less than 155
days
and so we found that this this kind of
price level is really important in terms
of how bitcoin you know price action has
interacted with uh with it
um you know
what we see is that whenever it kind of
retests that's generally time you want
to buy when we're in kind of an uptrend
um i'm trying you know
we'll talk about this i guess at the end
but i i'm trying to kind of get away
from this uh
concept of these binary bull and bear
markets and uh remind me to remind me to
talk about that at the end i don't want
to start like going off on a tangent
while i'm talking about this but i do
want to talk about that at the end
though um but yeah so whenever we're
below it's generally time to be cautious
um and then whenever you have these kind
of so when we break below you can have
bearish bias and then when we have these
underside failed retests that's when you
get that confirmation so we look at 2017
we bounced off this several times we
broke below after that blow off top and
we got confirmation
when we you know had this failed
underside re-test aka uh dead cat bounce
back up to that uh on-chain cost basis
and got rejected off of that i had three
more rejections uh headed in kind of the
depths of the bear when we finally broke
back above that that kind of signaled
that we were coming out of the you know
the bottom of the bear market
had this kind of mini you know uh rally
into into like 14k uh in uh 2019 which
was primarily driven by um
the plus token you know kind of
artificial lockup of coins moved back
down and we kind of just kind of went
sideways leading into the the covid
crash
finally broke back above and then we got
that confirmation so that confirmation
is really key
we got that confirmation in september of
last year after that move we just talked
about when we plateaued flushed down 20
we retested that cost basis there and
then moved higher without retesting it
at all
broke below in may so that's where you
would have you know ideally wanted to
want it to be risk off came back broke
above coming off of those lows in about
in like late august retested almost a
textbook reset at the end of september
of this year and most recently we
bounced off of this last week but then
this week we've now broken back below
and so to me you know this is this is a
signal of caution and so you know i
think um as an analyst you know your job
is to really remain objective and pay
attention to what the market is telling
you rather than you know what you want
what you want to happen or what you hope
is going to happen and you know at the
time just being objective we've broken
below the the short term holder cost
basis um it's you know it's time to be
cautious and you know all happily and
i'm not saying like i'm like a gigabyte
or like i'm insanely bearish i'm just
saying that you know i'm not a bull
until we reclaim this and that's at 53k
right now which also aligns with you
know the trillion dollar market cap
threshold for bitcoin as well as also a
pretty solid technical level as well uh
but you know until we reclaim that um
you know i remain to to be kind of
cautious and and um you know not
definitely not bullish uh you know
at least in kind of an extreme way um
and so you know for the bulls you
obviously want to see this reclaim
if this gets reclaimed then i'll happily
flip bullish again i'll say okay okay
guys the market has showed me that we've
now come back and seen strength um you
know and i'll happily you know go by
what the market is telling me but right
now the market is telling me to be
cautious because we're below the
short-term molar cost basis
for the bears you know bearish
confirmation would be you know retesting
this from the underside as as you can
see on the left-hand side of the chart
when we had these failed underside
re-tests
after 2017 heading into 2018
you know if you see a failed underside
retest that's confirmation that you
really want to be uh you know risk off
um so you know tldr as long as we're
below 53k i'm not bullish if we can
reclaim it i'll happily you know flip
bullish again and then bearish
confirmation would be this failed
underside re-test